on va maintenant parler d'un métier qui
me connaissaient bien parce que on a
tous à faire à un moment ou un autre à
son facteur ou assaf actrice c'est vous
nicolas bézy qui est directeur
opérationnel de la poste vous connaissez
bien le métier le métier le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il a beaucoup
évolué parce que le contexte a aussi
beaucoup changé les modes de
consommation évoluent et on écrit moi en
revanche on commente beaucoup plus sur
internet ce qui explique par exemple que
le facteur se balade de plus en plus
exactement
pascal la post a beaucoup évolué elle
continue d'évoluer dans un contexte de
société qui se transforme la société
vieillit on commence on commet beaucoup
plus sur internet dorénavant et donc en
conséquence le métier du facteur a
évolué et continuera d'évoluer beaucoup
ça veut dire qu'il ya des changements
qui sont déjà en place
pas seulement dans la tenue parce que
c'est vrai qu'on est tous remarqué on le
voit l'image que la tenue du facteur a
beaucoup bougé mais il n'ya pas que ça
il ya d'autres services qu'on ne connaît
pas forcément
alors le facteur est connecté dans un
monde qui se digitalise le facteur est
dorénavant reconnecter il roule en
électrique qui déconnecte dispose d'un
terminal numérique un smartphone dont
ils se servent pour effectuer ses
services et puis il et il roule en
électrique en ville électrique vélo
électrique est donc bien sûr on a moins
de lettres à distribuer mais on a
beaucoup plus de colis et des services
we are justement je reviens sur le mot
service et notion de service qui évolue
considérablement dans les présentes de
collyre à domicile vous le disais mais
pas seulement il ya d'autres choses
qu'on ne sait pas forcément auprès de
son facteur sans fard et sans peut
demander des nouvelles choses alors pas
seulement à domicile effectivement à la
demande des clients en général et venir
nous tous effectivement commande tout
sur internet je pense 1 et donc qu'un
seul nom qui reçoit encore des lettres
même s'il y en a moins
et on expédie également nicoli bien sûr
on peut expédier dorénavant depuis sa
boîte aux lettres est le facteur vient
récupérer le colis dans la boîte aux
lettres et puis bien sûr on peut choisir
la manière dont on va recevoir le colis
alors à son domicile un jour choisi et
puis ailleurs alors il ya pour le colis
ça j'ai bien compris mais aussi vraiment
le le facteur qui fait maintenant du
service à la personne entend de plus en
plus parler là on le voit sur sur cette
image bon la ccc plutôt simple on va
dire que c'est un recommandé qui est
donnée par le facteur ou la fin
13 mais il ya beaucoup d'autres choses
qui changent la russie alors la première
des choses puisque l'image le montre
c'est que on vieillit de plus en plus et
on lit à domicile et notre dans le sens
de nos services on va accompagner ce
bien vieillir à domicile et c'est le
sens de ce nouveau service qu'on appelle
veiller sur mes parents c'est le sens
d'un nouveau service également un autre
nouveau service avec le déploiement des
tablettes ardoise qui sont
spécifiquement conçus pour clientèle
senior on va également livrer des repas
des courses des médicaments à domicile
voilà tout un panel de services pour
lesquels la population nous fait bien
sûr confiance vous fait de
l'accompagnement des séniors numérique
sa gelée bien été gelé la table de jeu
pour ouvrir parce qu'à une marque dedans
donc ça sert à rien et voilà c'est une
tablette on peut apprendre à s'en servir
c'est à dire que mes parents mes grands
parents qui sont pas forcément connectés
peuvent apprendre à se servir de cette
tablette qui était simplifiée ça veut
dire que moi je souscris un contrat ça
se passe comment par exemple pour moi on
achète on achète tout simplement dans la
tablette là il ya un prix d'achat
classique
combien ça coûte 229 euros d'accord le
facteur vous livre la tablette et vous
fait une mise en main de cette tablette
il va vous expliquer les les premiers
pas il va vous l'installez si les
connecter à une borne wifi par exemple
il va où l'installer et puis il va vous
faire la mise en main de départ vous
expliquer les premiers pas dans
l'utilisation de cette tablette pourrait
effectivement rester en contact avec le
monde mais également avec sa famille
elle ça c'est très important parce
qu'aujourd'hui sur la tablette on à la
photo des enfants les petits enfants
on a plein de choses et puis on est
complètement déconnecté si on peut pas
par exemple revoir en replay les
émissions de france télé ou plein plein
plein d'autres choses ça sous-entend
peut-être qu'il faut que je paye un
abonnement en syrie que cette tablette
oui avec cette tablette il ya un
abonnement une dizaine d'euros par mois
pour pouvoir bénéficier des nouvelles
tous les jours
et puis de toute l'information et de la
connexion encore une fois avec la
famille puisque on construit un album
familial qu'on vient remettre ensuite
aux personnes qui le souhaitent donc le
facteur tel qu'on le connaissait avant
avec le simple courrier il existe
toujours mais il a beaucoup évolué et on
l'a compris à fonctionner les modes de
vie qu'ils ont
bien changé il est adapté les numériques
il est branché
maintenant il y en a peut-être qui nous
regardaient christien ça serait bien
pour moi est ce qu un âge limite par
exemple pour devenir facteur ou factrice
nicolas bézy directeur opérationnel de
la poste y'a pas d'âge limite et
j'allais dire au contraire l'expérience
dans mon des services dans le monde de
la livraison est plutôt un atout
si on veut rejoindre ce métier de
facteur filles et garçons bien sûr fille
garçon tous âges formation particulière
ou pas alors pas de formation
particulière il faut voir être à l'aise
avec le contact virer la relation avec
les personnes et un entretien à
l'origine il ya quelques tests
psychotechniques maths français
l'orientation et puis un entretien avec
un jury de postiers le salaire le
salaire ça corresponde au smic voilà
quelques quelques avantages sociaux sur
le logement notamment pour les primo et
les premiers postiers et puis un
accompagnement social sont le logement
les enfants les loisirs un smartphone à
disposition également pour une
initiation personnel comment postule si
on est intéressé par exemple en
bourgogne franche comté par le métier de
facteur autres actrices
eh bien on se rend sur le post sur le
site de la poste la poste recrute point
fr aujourd'hui on recrute cette année on
va recruter 289 acteurs bourgogne
franche comté
c'est très bien ça je rappelle que ce
sont des contrats de droit privé parce
que l on entend beaucoup de choses sur
la poste ont dit ce sont des
fonctionnaires ont concédé y voilà ce
sont des contrats de droit privé en cdi
en tout cas c'est sûr avec la chute du
courrier papier le métier de facteur
évoluer recrute en bourgogne francs